Paul Austin is a big advocate of micro
dosing LSD he says it has many benefits
about 45 minutes after i microdose i
noticed just a general mood enhancement
it's a little bit easier to smile I'm a
little bit more extroverted I'm less in
my head and more engaged in my outer
world I noticed that when I'm working on
projects like for example if I'm writing
something it's much easier to write kind
of having the ideas come forward so
generally it just it kind of smooths
things out and makes it much more like
you're going through life with with a
bit more it makes it a bit easier to go
through life so this morning I woke up I
meditated I went to the sauna this is
something I do quite consistently and
then of course I took a micro dose the
businessman says taking tiny doses of
the psychedelic drug just 10 to 20
micrograms kicks your brain into higher
gear neuro enhancement is a new word for
an old activity using drugs to enhance
cognitive affective and motor
performance one type of neuro enhancer
became widespread during the Second
World War
Nazi Germany pumped its soldiers full of
methamphetamine to make them better
fighters it was marketed as pervert in
civilians also took a fancy to the drug
that banished tiredness and hunger and
made you euphoric for a while you could
even buy chocolates laced with it but
speed soon became illegal in Germany and
many other countries because of the
serious side effects still speed and
many other drugs continued to be widely
used for their purported neuro enhancing
effects in addition to LSD there are
beta blockers and modafinil and
methylphenidate often called by the
brand name Ritalin
borås [ __ ] or is a
psychopharmacologist he says that less
than 1% of the people who take the drugs
are regular consumers which is probably
due to the ambivalent effects they have
takes such a substance the desired
results are often offset by ones I don't
want a motivation and alertness might be
enhanced but other cognitive capacities
will be diminished one way psychotropic
drugs work is by intervening in the flow
of neurotransmitters increasing their
concentration or activating their
receptors neurotransmitters carry
messages from one nerve cell to the next
in the brain and throughout the body
drugs can increase some neural activity
but that also has side effects related -
of treatment comes in too much pure
stimulants quite often cause headaches
insomnia and loss of appetite they are
quite common side effects if you mention
I invented a substance 9 name tottaly
the name become the more serious side
effects such as delusions psychotic
episodes and depression occur in less
than 1% of cases were invaded by unda
inputs and episode north as to micro
doses of LSD which are now so popular
among dynamic young professionals
professor credo has words of warning LSD
extreme potent LSD is a very powerful
agent we know it can have serious side
effects the name will come from cool
side effects of chronic consumption of
small doses have so far not been
researched at all as LSD is behind a
substance my personal opinion is that
one should not take LSD regularly not
even micro doses theater the message is
messing with the brain is a risky
business if you want a little
stimulation without too many side
effects
nice cup of coffee might be the way to
go it has a positive impact on cognitive
function
[Music]